the deutsche Comerford Himani Bremen and
conductor Pavel Gaddafi musical allies
on a mission to create a new Beethoven
they want their version of the Beethoven
symphonies to suit the 21st century they
call it the Beethoven project
you
and why another cycle who needs another
cycle we will always in need another
cycle Bremen in northern Germany from
here the Deutsche comma phenomena is
conquering the musical world
Pavel Yaffe has been the orchestra's
artistic director since 2004 and since
then almost anything seems possible
sold-out concerts resounding world tours
and acclaimed recordings the next
milestone performances of all nine
Beethoven symphonies at the Beethoven
fest in Bonn when I met them and I heard
them play bet home and it became clear
that this this sounds how I wanted to
sound is that anvil yeah it took years
until we were able to produce a
characteristic sound quickly for Holly
and I saw Stella at this point a
different mood suddenly comes in a
fateful mood as I see it after Symphony
Middleton via and Beethoven was a
humanist he did not compose only for a
concert audience he had a message for
the whole of humanity and his message is
being heard around the world
the Beethoven project spells success for
the orchestra yawn for the Isaac on are
the 30 years ago when they started the
prospects were not good it was only
going to happen if people believed in
the impossible movie flatly hoped our
views on how things should sound in
better words infinite coincided and the
willingness to go deeper and find the
little details and obsess on every
detail which I love about this Orchestra
because they are obsessive like I am
percussionist Stefon drop lives in a
formerly squatted building in the center
of Bremen within spits Alison specialize
in one instrument but I see myself not
only as a percussionist rather as an
artist I came to percussion quite late I
used to play the horn in an orchestra
and for a long time I played the piano
you don't love your Lonni Stefan rob has
been a member of the Deutsche come up in
Romani Bremen since 1996 he's been part
of the Beethoven project from the
beginning the project began back in 2004
and it continues to make demands of the
musicians touch again steel our style
has developed over the years
I don't just play as I like it's
something we've worked to achieve we've
discussed it many times is the sound too
hard or too soft
it took years until we were able to
produce our characteristic sound quickly
now we get up to full speed fast like a
Ferrari
but we still want to be even quicker
more involved than emotionally
downbeats parents beth horon has this
strange progression you have a one of
the greatest symphonies ever written
like the Eroica all oh and then you have
the fifth that everybody everybody knows
and yet in the middle between these two
great masterpieces you have something
that that is basically a classical
Symphony something that that should have
followed the second thing
maybe it was a piece that had to be in
between these two major milestones
because one had to maybe get away from
the Eroica to kind of it's like that
sorbet between the meals just to clean
the palate just just to just to make
sure that you can you're ready to go on
to something else
I'm dzasta Lou you've just blitz at this
point at different mood suddenly comes
in a fateful mood as I see it it touches
you for one's ever it's difficult to say
how it's something huge and dark if I
see something you can't escape from of
us nobody can get away from this thing
it's the touch of fate which can enter
any life at any moment and every time we
play this passage I sense that the whole
orchestra is experiencing this feeling
it's cancer okay Cyril Jesus Kofu
Deutsch kid
ish peers they're gonna part some
editing I like playing viola because I
love the sound very much it's deeper
it's a more easygoing instrument you
don't have to play so high also fast
does is and this is a viola it's my it's
my instrument it's what I earn my money
with one asked how long do you think
this instrument is Oh didn't get 20
years old
high school I think 20 also mm-hmm 5000
20 or 30 see 10 anyone else what did you
say 100 ah not bad
250 years old the musicians of the
Comerford how many are frequent guests
in the classrooms of their partners
school they try to make the children
curious to get them enthusiastic about
music in Finnish Watts this is Lucy few
hours la was askance fish dish I think
it's very important to test whether
water I do as a musician touches people
out there is it possible to get it
across to children and young people can
the message of classical music only be
understood by people who are properly
dressed sitting in a concert hall or is
it something children can understand
this is a great opportunity for us does
it feel wants to cross our shores
I just kind of say it goes on like that
for ten minutes and wash tortillas
Hanuman detergent chemical on a theme
and treat me like English naira
behind the scenes the orchestra has 15
employees supporting the musicians the
audience doesn't see them but they
contribute their share to the fine
performances in the management office
concert programs are designed tours are
planned and media appointments arranged
the message of the Beethoven project is
being heard around the world for CD lost
in noise pattern shall I tell you the
latest news yet to look solid you know
that magazine in the States the absolute
sound hugging gold every year they give
a golden ear award and the recording of
the first and fifth Beethoven's with
parvo has won it it's great and it's a
rave review as well guide the special
yarn for devices yarn i thirty years ago
when they started the prospects were not
good no one wanted yet another orchestra
there was no need for one and it was
quite clear that it was only going to
happen if people believed in the
impossible
it took the uncompromising attitude that
these musicians have and which you can
hear in the Beethoven performances zord
oddly to be honest
ish mutters it's 8:50 young you know
Jesus ya fattah Java I've been doing
this for 40 years this year it's exactly
40 years so it's a kind of anniversary
for me
you need strong nerves to do it as a job
in the way that we do with the touring
and all the stresses that go along with
it but it's always a great joy as well
it's fun when it works when you see that
the practice has paid off the artifice
lives with her family in a suburb of
Bremen
she began violin lessons when she was
just four years old in 1991 after
studying music and initial steps as a
professional she applied to join the
Comerford Himani then still based in
Frankfurt a couple of dings not truly my
father said think about it carefully
is it a secure job I was always
influenced by my parents so I tried out
somewhere else as well but then I
decided to take the riskier option I
just like the idea who done talking she
even by my dismay and what another fall
javi said to avoid a comeback shortly
after I started in the orchestra there
was a huge crisis Frankfurt suddenly
said we've run out of money so you
either have to slim down radically or go
somewhere else what a nursing him so
there I was looking at the situation and
thinking well I wonder how this is going
to turn out now I've been here 18 years
and I don't regret it
perhaps our height out of the crisis
emerged an opportunity to move to Bremen
and make a new start
if you have something that short and so
powerful as a kind of a motto it's not
even a theme
everybody can remember that even in our
time of reduced attention spans and MTV
generation even they can understand pom
pom pom pom
from either that the music loses
something if it is just one of those big
dramatic gesture after dramatic gesture
maybe sometimes the scale of everything
is too big in this traditional view so
for me to try to convince notice a
saying look it's not Papa Papa its yep a
Papa yet at a town out of these four
notes he constructs the entire symphony
everything is literally variation
augmentation diminution Papa Papa Papa
Papa Tata team all of a sudden that
becomes a phrase or or or or but it
comes to Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa
you
do the stellosphere misty in my view
this is the strongest passage in
Beethoven's entire symphonic output at
least up until his ninth symphony
Beethoven was a humanist he did not
compose only for a concert audience he
had a message for the whole of humanity
let's eat all of a sudden he focuses all
humanity on one individual and he makes
one instrument express this individuals
feelings I never meant Oxford
you
- I have an ambivalent attitude to this
over sometimes I take it out of its case
and first of all nothing seems to work I
have to fiddle with the screws and make
adjustments it's very sensitive I really
have to work at our relationship
believed Hedden worse than the default
innit
Woolridge Kunis joined the comma
phenomena in 1988 at the time when wind
instruments were added to the strings a
key component in creating the sound of
conics oboe is the reed made from French
Reed gained Manhattan Muddy Hoffman does
earth he always hope it's going to be
the best Reed you've ever made if you
buy it from someone else you're somehow
dependent on them but I like to be
independent at five making these things
as a real pain you're happy if you make
one good one in every 10 Reed's but you
have to accept that you're going to
throw the other nine away it was more
for Kaufman
it's not bad
let's see what we can catch today
whenever possible furnish likes to spend
time at a fish pond he owns not far from
Raymond today he's here with his two
daughters and their friends a moment--
can easy that I enjoy coming here it
gives me some balance being out here in
nature is a way of relieving stress
sometimes I sit here all night and fish
for eels it's really important for me to
have this job then art were designers
let's finish this group adore master
Gallia awesome iron he can create a
problem for my marriage when I stand
here at the water's edge just looking
and not noticing anything else around me
our but I did watch rescue a drowning
boy from the water so my wife has
forgiven me rather one day I have mana
for me other fruits but Celia
and all of a sudden you have something
that that goes away from all the the the
human issues and concentrates on our
nature
why it's so touching is because you're
all of a sudden you see that maybe all
the stereotypes that we thought about
Beethoven and these famous images of bet
on are not true at all
it's not meant as a soundtrack it's not
not meant as an illustrative piece of
work
it is the mood the atmosphere of it the
air around it that's what makes a
difference
this new Stella
to play this passage you have to take
risks if it works it's a lot of fun and
I think it's really special to listen to
there's a note here written as f that
does not appear in the natural tone
series to sound it you have to stop it
that's to say put the hand into the Bell
often childish and with a hand tool this
isn't an Alfonzo hum Mahad it's a
question of nerve a lot of it is very
exposed
and because the mouthpiece is outside
it's somehow out in the open so the
risks are high and if you're not totally
fit and if you don't hit the notes right
in the middle you can make a mistake
come and everyone will hear it you know
like many members of the Deutsche come
off at emoni Bremen Elka shoots a hooker
man spends some of her time giving
private tuition at her home
among her students is eleven-year-old
charlotta
Reynold in porn you if you hit the note
here it won't sound so good and here
it's the same but if you hit it right in
the middle it can really vibrate as it
should tell fing your things or feel oh
[ __ ] like many people compare it to
competitive sport the brass players are
usually there an hour before the
rehearsal to warm up you need all your
muscles your breath has to be flowing
you relax your lips or tense them a bit
depending on how much you played the day
before not embossing for time for taco
bar
give the fish gone I really like going
to rehearsals I never think oh dear
another rehearsal it is tiring sometimes
but I'm not constantly thinking I would
rather not go to work I've heard of
other orchestras where that's so but
I've never seen that here here I've
owned omnia Luke
this is a dancing phony from beginning
to an end it's a dance
when you have the beginning - yeah
yeah you can see the judge it's to me
it's so visual that I can't even conduct
it any other way because I need to make
these gestures it's a kind of a kind of
an introduction tool to a dance
the most interesting thing about this
Symphony and most misunderstood thing is
the last moment because last movement
has traditionally always been
interpreted as a kind of a relentless
motoric movement da da da da dum perdón
perdón perdón perdón Patel yeah but I
can't imagine who would dance like that
or what kind of dance would it be and
who would dance it and then after a
little bit of reading you realize that
it is an Irish dance and you see Dom
parody read reading para daridiridara du
redd redeem pray para Dara Dara Don para
para
this is VDP V it's like a great orgy
which gets ever more enthusiastic but it
still has to be a dance as you would
dance at a party the rhythm mustn't be
too heavy or it becomes laborious
Bewdley
just like any orchestra would i play the
rhythm
um did our two semi quavers and a quaver
but i have to play it a bit shorter in a
more lively way
this dance that started as a kind of a
nice sort of ordinary folk dance turns
into this kind of a maniacal mad crazy
Galip to hell
the Beethoven project continues coming
up in part three paavo Yaffe travels to
his hometown of Tallinn and thrills the
crowds at the Estonian Song Festival
back in Bremen conductor yari completes
his CD recording of all the Beethoven
symphonies
ix is a kind of a a a landmark it's it's
not a symphony anymore it is it's a kind
of a legend and the Kama philharmonie
heads to bond for the Beethoven fest in
the next part of the Beethoven project
you